going to share a special feature that's
right we have Tunney who we had on the
show earlier the inspirational
eight-year-old and he and Grandmaster
Christian Carla tried to break
Nakamura's puzzle Ross rocker let's see
how they did
oh boy
[Music]
thank you guys I'm here with Connie our
special guest today
and we're going to try to break some
records as we will do some puzzle rush
and we have the record holder here at
the the US Chess Championship Nakamura
has 55 I think we can break that Tony
let's let's go ahead and try it out
we're going to do a tandem puzzle rush
you're going to do one I'm going to do
the next one play again you start that's
a good start
take this one I think we're on pace to
break
Nakamura's record already oh sorry
yep that was a tricky one where's the
checkmate where is the checkmate there's
no check wait we're on time so far
that's good that's good
four more minutes left a lot of Pete I
call the PCs yes that's a good check
right there that's almost made he's
trying to check with us
let's take like this no mistakes so far
that's really good 14 14 points
beautiful beautiful work
hmm this one is not easy Frank I see me
yep I'm going to go with this one
nice one yes I think you you see it I
see it if I see it you must see it as
well there we go there we go well done
we're going to take this one yes we're
going to take this one we're going to
cover see 18 points and we have three
minutes left
that's pretty good all right let's take
this guy
no mistakes so far in Texas very okay I
like that one checkmate is not possible
let's go here night you're saying night
I'll go with you all right Chuck
checkmate there we go you see I need I
need the help sometimes
if I said you said okay who they need to
use all of our pieces tonight yes yes
very nice 23 Chuck Chuck we're going to
sacrifice the Queen and check out the
baby okay there we go now I see it I see
it you see it let's suppose he was two
more minutes left to Mormon that's
hmm I think you're on the right track
there I think you're on no that's okay
we still have a lot of a lot of lives
left well actually just two of them
I see it mm-hmm that's the move
that's the money move like Maurice likes
to say I've taken off to - II - very
nice 28 we're going to break some
records or are we take this he wants to
do here I'm gonna go here yes yes I
think so
that's one check no that doesn't work
okay oh man Chuck Chuck mm-hmm this one
is tricky
no it takes e4 it's not sexy for oh all
right I'm going that way yes that is the
right one g3 meter yes very good very
good very good
294 I think so yeah yeah take on day two
first because 94 c3 and uh Queen you
weren't able to take it I think I'm
going to go here yes yes 33 seconds
that's okay that's okay that's this is a
tricky one I'm going to go with this one
Chuck Chuck take the Queen see I see
that's one back jack ah I think we have
to go for no for equality I think we
have to go for equality sorry [ __ ] yeah
no 34 still pretty good 34 good job and
that's going to be it for the counts
corner
you
[Music]